Bố cố phòng nha ngày 18m, nhưng này đã mắt đầu của tập trận 2 quân quy mô lời mang tên cơn bảo tháng bẩy,
kéo dài năm ngày, bố xử thăm ra của hơn 1 chẳng năm 2019 và mẹ làm miệng bị xí,
dân ra tại các vùng biển thả bình dương, bắt mằng dương, bàn tích và cắt sph theo bộ cố phòng nha,
của dễ tập nhầm kìm chà mức độ sân xàng của hạn lâu chỉ trong việc thực hiện gác, chến rực phí trên thống,
sự dụng cuối tâm xa và nhiều công nghệ tin tình khác, bắt gồm cả hệ thống không nghe lãi,
ngoài ra cứ lực lượng sẽ luyện tập trúng tông gầm, bảo vệ khu vực đồng quân cũng như hò đậu kinh tế.
Bố cố phòng nha cho biết hơn 1 chăm 2 mẹ mẹ bài và mời hệ thống trên lượng bởi vì những sẽ thăm ra của tập trận này.
Rồi đó, ở đây rằng đường mô xí f, tư lệ hả quân nha ngồi nhậm chất năm 2020,
hả mi tư dự sẽ chức tiếp chi vì của tập trận theo hầu hết các bạn xíu hạn công khai,
nha sự hiểu lực lượng hả quân mạnh thứ 3 thế giới sau Trung Quốc và Mỹ,
tư nhiên lực lượng này đã phải gắn chiếu một loạt tổng thất lớn trong cuộc súng lộn với ucol qua nha.